اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير نحيكم الى
بانوراما نناقش فيها مجموعه من الملفات
وافعه عناوين ملفات النقاش لهذا المساء
اوستن في زياره مفاجئه للعراق المعلن
بالتاكيد عن الشراكه الاستراتيجيه وتحت
الطاولات تحضير ايران وميليشياتها من
مهاجمه جنوده فما هو مستقبل هذا التحالف
في الملف الثاني المعارضه التركيه تختار
كمال كلتشدار رئيسه حزب الشعب الجمهوري
لمواجهه اردوغان على الرئاسه هل هي فرصه
نجاح ولماذا اختلفت المعارضه عليهم
وفي الملف الثالث طموحات الخفيه للقوه
الكبرى كتاب يتحدث في جزء منه عن رغبه
ايران في ضمان امنها من خلال الحصول على
السلاح النووي وفرض نفسها على محيطها
الاقليمي طموحات ايران التي لا تعلنها
[موسيقى]
ونحييكم الى الملف الاول زياره مفاجئه الى
بغداد لم يتضمنها برنامج الجوله وزير
الدفاع الامريكيه الشرق الاوسطيه التي
بداها الاحد بالاردن وتشمل مصر واسرائيل
وفاروا وصوله مطار بغداد قلاوستن ان
زيارته تهدف لاعاده التاكيد على الشراكه
الاستراتيجيه بين الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه والعراق كما اكد مسؤول في وزاره
الدفاع للصحفيين اكد ان واشنطن ستقدم
تعهدا بالحفاظ على وجود قواتها في العراق
الزياره غير المعلنه تاتي في سياق حركه
دبلوماسيه مؤخرا حيث استقبل فيها
المسؤولون العراقيون عددا من مسؤولي بلدان
اقليميه ودوليه كما انها قبيل ذكرى
العشرين للغزو الامريكي للعراق في العشرين
من مارس 2003 حينها كان وسط اخر قائدا عام
للقوات الامريكيه في العراق بعد الحرب
رئيس الوزراء العراقي اكد حرصه على تعزيز
العلاقات مع واشنطن الا انه ذكر بضروره
اتباعه علاقات متوازنه مع المحيط الاقليمي
والدولي تستند الى المصالح المشتركه
يجب ان نكون قادرين على العمل بسلامه
وامان لتنفيذ دورنا الحيوي لتقديم المشوره
للقوات العراقيه لذا اود ان اشكر رئيس
الوزراء السوداني ووزير الدفاع العباسي
على التزامهما اليوم بضمان ان قوات
التحالف الموجوده في العراق بطلب عراقي
ستتم حمايتها من العناصر التابعه وغير
التابعه للدوله نركز على مهمه هزيمه داعش
هذا هو هدفنا الوحيد هنا والتهديدات
والهجمات على قواتنا تقوض مهمه
[موسيقى]
تحيه لك يا استاذ ريم وتحيه لاهلنا اهلنا
في تونس اهلا بك
طبعا
ليس غريب عن المسرح العمليات العراقي هو
كان القائد العام للقوات الامريكيه وهو
اخر قائد عام للقوات الامريكيه في العراق
بعد غزو العراق سنه 2003 ويعلم بان هذه
الحكومه هي حكومه الاطار التنسيقي وبين
الميليشيات التي كانت تستهدف المصالح
الامريكيه هي اذرع الاحزاب داخل الاطار
التنسيقي فاذا امريكا تتعامل مع هذه
الحكومه
بنظام الفري انمي العدو الصديق لان هذه هي
الاحزاب الذي
وميليشيات التي كانت تستهدف المصالح
الامريكيه في العراق اعلن بان تعزيز
الشراكه الاستراتيجيه اي تفعيل
اتفاقيه الاطار الاستراتيجي وان القوات
الامريكيه موجوده حسب الطلب الحكومه
العراقيه وايضا نحن ملت
بمحاربه داعش وهو هدفنا الوحيد وان القوات
الامريكيه الموجوده هي عباره عن مدربين
وفنيين واستشاريين هذه كلها معروفه ولكن
لن يعلن للاعلام ما هو الهدف من هذه
الزياره الهدف من هذه الزياره كان على
الحكومه بغداد انهاء الخلافات بينها وبين
حكومه اقليم كردستان وايضا تشكيل قوه
عسكريه مشتركه ولمسك الاراضي الرخوه في
كركوك والموصل على حدود اقليم كردستان
وايضا انهاء الكلي دور البري الرابط بين
طهران ودمشق وبيروت وايضا سحب الميليشيات
الذي هي اذرع لاحزاب داخل الاطار التنسيقي
من مسرح العمليات السوري وايضا عدم عدم
عدم الميول الكثير لايران المسك من العصا
من المنتصف
والقوات الامريكيه الموجوده هنا هي قوات
صديقه ولكن لو عدنا على القوات الامريكيه
الموجوده في العراق هي قوات نعم تدريبيه
واستشاريه وتقدم المعلومات الاستخباريه
وفي العمليات الاخيره في صحراء الانبار
حتى شاركت القوات العراقيه بالاسناد الجوي
القريب في فاذا القوات القوات العراقيه في
حاجه ماسه للقوات الامريكيه ولكن
عميد قيسون هذا هذا كذلك سؤال يضاف الى
مجموعه تساؤلات لحضرتك لمحت لها خليني
انقل واسمح لي بنقل هذه النقطه لضيفي من
بغداد دكتور علي دكتور علي هل تتفق مع
العميد قيسون بانه هناك نوايا امريكيه
لتخفيف الروابط بين طهران وبغداد وهل تنجح
اداره في ذلك
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم وصلى الله على
محمد وعلى اله الطيبين الطاهرين احييك
سيدتي الكريمه ضيفك العزيز جمهور قناتكم
الكرام في الحقيقه المعروف ان العراق
يرتبط مع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
باتفاقيه استراتيجيه وهذه الاتفاقيه لديها
لها ابعاد كثيره ونقاط مشتركه منها
التعاون العسكري والتعاون الاقتصادي
والثقافي والاجتماعي ولكن طغى عليها في
السنين السابقه الجانب العسكري والامني
اكثر بسبب ظرف الذي مر به العراق
ومحاربه داعش الارهابي
وهذا ما يعني اخذ المنحه منحى الامني
الجانب الاكبر من الاتفاقيه
قبل يعني اقل من شهر كان هناك وفد عراقي
برئاسه وزير الخارجيه العراقي ذهب الى
واشنطن
وناقشه معه هذه الاتفاقيه وركز على ان
يكون هنالك ابعاد اخرى من ضمنها البعد
الاقتصادي واليوم نحن نتطلع الى تعاون مع
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ليس فقط في
التعاون كما جاء على لساني وزير الدفاع
الامريكي ولكن اسمح لي فقط هذه الاتفاقيه
شافتها بعض الخلافات تعلم حضرتك بان هناك
ذلك تحركات فداخل العراقي نسبها البعض
لقوات تدعم او مدعومه بالعكس من طهران
وكانت محرجه العراق في فترات معينه
الحكومه العراقيه حكومه بغداد كانت محرجه
من الجانب الامريكي على خلفيه هذه
الاتفاقيه فالسؤال مطروح دكتور علي لما
حضرتك تحدث عن تعاون عن استراتيجيه هذا
مفهوم ولكن يبدو بان هذه المعادله التي
حاولت العراق تحقيقها بين طهران وبين
واشنطن صارت صعبه في هذا التوقيت العراق
سيتوجه لاين
لا اولا يعني قبل لا يجيني صار سؤالين
جنابك الكريم طرحتيهم خلي نجاوب على
السؤال الاول السؤال الاول لانه هل هذه
الزياره تحمل ابعاد قضيه يعني وجود
الايران وكذا انا لا اعتقد نحمل الزياره
اكثر ما تحتمل يعني هو وزير الخارجيه
بنفسه يقول انا جايلي هدفين هدف التعاون
الاستراتيجي والامني والثاني هو
لمحاربه داعش المتبقي والجيوب المتبقيه
والاماكن الرخوه الموجوده في داخل العراق
وخارجه اما يعني زياره واحده تجي تقلص كل
هذه الها ابعاد بهالشكل هذا ما اعتقد يعني
خصوصا انه زياره وزير الدفاع هي لم تكن
مخصوصه فقط في العراق وانما قد شملت
المنطقه اكيد تحمل ملفات اخرى ولكن
الملفات اخرى ولكن خليني فقط الى اربيل مع
العميد قيسون لانه العميد قيسون تحدث عن
ابعد من ذلك قال بان الموضوع لا يقتصر فقط
على ملف داعش هو تحدث عن هذه الاتفاقيه
الامنيه بطريقه اوسع وتحدث حتى عن الاطار
التنسيقي هكذا عم يتقيسون تود القول بانه
الملفات في هذه المرحله تبدو شائكه اكثر
وحسسه اكثر
نسيت ان اذكر نقطه ذكرها وزير الدفاع على
مخيم الهول مخيم الهول انا اعتبره مصنع
للارهاب لانهاء الاطفال الموجودين في هذا
المخيم يرضعون التطرف والارهاب مع حليب
امهاتهم فسوف تواجه المنطقه جيل جديد من
الارهاب اكثر دمويه واكثر وحشيه من
الاجيال السابقه فاذا يجب تفكيك هذا هذا
المخيم وايضا على العراق ساحب مواطنيه من
هذا المخيم وادخالها في دورات تاهيليه
طويله العمد وسهرهم داخل المجتمع كما فعلت
المملكه العربيه السعوديه مع عناصر من
القاعده قبل سنين عديده فاذا مخيم الهول
يجب ان يفكك لان هذا هو مصنع للهراب وايضا
علي ان لا انسى ذكر لوستين نقطه مهمه جدا
هنالك مساعدات عسكريه جاءت للعراق الى
وزاره الدفاع من ض هذه المعدات العسكريه
هنالك معدات عسكريه خصصت لاقليم كردستان
من ضمنها طائرات مسيره وزاره الدفاع او
الحكومه العراقيه لن تسلم هذه المعدات
العسكريه الى اقليم كردستان فذكر لوستن
هذا الموضوع وايضا هدد بقطع المساعدات
العسكريه اذا تصرفت الحكومه العراقيه
باتجاه اقليم كردستان كعدو وليس كصديق
وجزء من العراق وايضا لا ننسى ايران ايران
هي ايران سوف لن استاذه ايران سوف لن
تستهدف عسكريا مطلقا ليس هنالك اراده
امريكيه حقيقيه لاستهداف المنشات
النوويه وايضا اسرائيل تملك الايرانيه نعم
العفو اسرائيل لا تملك القدرات
الاستراتيجيه ولكن لا تملك القدرات
العملياتي لاستهداف المنشات النوويه لا
تملك طائرات ارضاع جوي ولا تملك القنابل
الخاصه
ولكن لم نصل الى حد الحديث عن استهداف
عسكري نتحدث فقط عن امكانيه استقطاب حضرتك
تعرف بانه نحن على بعد ايام من الذكرى
العشرين للغزو الامريكي العراق وكانت هناك
انتقادات لواشنطن بانها بعد عمليه الغزو
هذه وكانها اخلت الطريق لطهران فكانت
سنوات من التقارب العراقي الايراني فهل
تعتقد بانه في الذكرى العشرين ستعيد
واشنطن ترتيب حساباتها واعاده بغداد
لتكون اقرب منها باختصار السؤال الاثنين
بايجاز ان تكرمتما
ابدا
لكي لا نلوي عمق الحقيقه
امريكا هي الذي سمحت لايران ان يكون لها
موطئ قدم في العراق لو لا امريكا لم
استطعت ايران ان يوجد لها موطئ اصبع قدم
في العراق واصبحت ايران شريكه في الولايه
على العراق فاذا هو هنالك خطوط حمراء
وضعتها امريكا ايران حاولت تخطي هذه
الخطوط الحمراء الذي وضعتها امريكا في
الولايه على العراق فلذلك امريكا تحاول ان
تعيد ايران الى تحت هذه الخطوط الحمراء
الذي وضعتها امريكا في العراق دكتور علي
نفس السؤال حضرتك
اني بس عندي ملاحظه قبل هذه يعني للاسف
الشديد انا طبعا هم من زمان نتعامل مع
الاخوه في قناه العربيه والعربيه الحدث
جزء من وقتنا ونقطع اجتماعاتنا وكذا
والتزاماتنا حتى نحضر لديهم اذا كان وقتكم
ما يسمح وكان انتو تسمعون جهه وجهه نظر
واحد احنا نحترم هذا الشيء ولكن كان كان
المفروض ما تدعونا ما تدعونا لهذا المساله
يعني حضرتك ضيف
كل الاحترام ولكن الكلمه
على كل حال اقول مع احترامي لما ذكره
ضيفكم الكريم وان هناك تهديد للحكومه
العراقيه وقضيه اقليم كردستان انا اعتقد
هذا لا يخرج عن التحليل السياسي هو ما
موجود هذا المساله مساله طبيعيه وزير
الدفاع حضر هنالك وضع عمي ما تفضل تنبيه
صحيحه ملفات يناقشها لكن مو بهالشكل وان
يوجه يعني تهديد للحكومه العراقيه وانه
بالعكس العلاقات الامريكيه العراقيه تشهد
اليوم يعني باعلها مستوياتها تواصل بين
رئيس الوزراء رئيس الامريكي هناك زياره
مرتقبه لرئيس الوزراء الى الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه على كل المستويات هنالك
يعني علاقات متينه علاقات منفتحه العراق
يحاول اليوم حكومته الجديده ان ينفتح مع
الاقليم مع دول العربيه مع الدول الاقليم
ومع الدول يعني الكبرى ولذلك ما موجود هذه
المساله ولو كانت مساله بها توصيات كذا قد
تكون مقبوله لكن تهديد وبهالشكل هذا
وكانما احنا نتلقى اوامر اعتقد هذا ما
موجود به بالحوار العراقي الامريكي او مع
اي بلد اخر العراق له سياده له كرامته وهو
محتفظ بهذه المساله ويدافع عنها بصوره
صحيحه نعم العراق يبحث عن توازن وهذا ما
جاء بكلمه رئيس الوزراء عندما استقبل وزير
الدفاع هو حريص على ان يوازن العلاقات
بنوات المتحده الامريكيه بين ايران بين
المملكه العربيه السعوديه دول العربيه
الشقيقه الكريمه وباقي دول العالم نحن
حريصون وخصوصا في هذه المرحله اعلى مصلحه
داخل العراق ولكن دكتور علي لماذا تحدثت
حضرتك فقط لافهم وجهه نظر حضرتك لماذا
تحدثت عن التهديد الامريكي لم يتحدث احد
عن تهديه تحدثنا عن محاوله استقطاب عن
محاوله دعم
المصالح المشتركه بين البلدين هل تعتقد من
وجهه نظرك بانه واشنطن فعلا تود او هي
تسعى لدعم هذه الشراكه لتقريب حكومه بغداد
اكثر منها وحضرتك تعلم بانه السياسه قائمه
على مصالح مشتركه وعلى توافقات
واضح جدا وانا قلت انه سبق قبل يعني اقل
من شهر كان هناك وفد عراقي رفيع المستوى
كان يزور مع شنطه خرج بنتائج جدا كبيره
العراق اليوم خصوصا في حكومه سيد السوداني
ومتطلع العلاقات عراقيه
عربيه عراقيه اقليميه عراقيه عالميه تكون
مصلحه العراق والتوازن وان لا يكون العراق
محسوب على جانب جانب اخر وانا بالعكس
يستثمر يستثمر موقعه الجغرافي وقربه من
الجميع في تقريب وجهات النظر وهذا ما حدث
يعني اعتقد حتى في حكومه السيد الكاظمي
عندما صارت هنالك يعني اجتماعات للمملكه
العربيه السعوديه مع ايران
حديث كان هنالك لي تقارب النظر بين ايران
والبعض الدول العربيه بين ايران وتركيا
نحول العراق نريد ان نحول العراق الى
مساحه جذب وتفاهم وليس الى صراع وان كنت
طرفا بهذه الصح على كل نحن سنبقى في
متابعه تبعات هذه الزياره وربما ننقشها في
حلقات اخرى او تشكركم الجزيل الشكر من
بغداد الدكتور علي الحوراني عضو طيار
الحكمه الوطني ومن اربيل العميد حسين
قيسون المحلل الاستراتيجيه شكرا جزيلا لكم
نتوقف مع فاصل من بعد سنعود لنتابع
انقسام في المعرضات التركيه بعد اختيار
كلتشدار اوغلولي مواجهتي اردوغان